didn't really think twice about him and
the audition just thought everybody was
funny and nice but thank you
then we started working and he just was
so good at his job but also very kind
and very funny and just knew what he
wanted and very level-headed and was
just a very good boss
why Caitlyn oh I don't think anybody
would need to hear me explain why based
on it took me a while though I really
had to work at you you did yeah she
personally I really I really put it out
there you yeah you yeah Advanced on me
Charlie's house I thought wow this is
wildly inappropriate it's only a
harassment if it doesn't lead to
marriage and children you have a woman
this beautiful this talented very kind
that's what you're looking for go on
there we go
what did the candle go out